and guys thank you for all the warm
words - that was one of the hardest
things for me and getting started a long
time ago in this it's just accepting
compliments and being in front it was it
was 350 videos that I made before I
wasn't totally embarrassed by myself
watching them back I couldn't watch them
back and 700 until I was actually
inspired by myself so it's still even
like I love me in the 100 ons I love
doing the groups like this is a
highlight for me coming to Boston and
I'm still getting used to taking the
complements and so thank you means a lot
and it's great to be here so I think
your purpose comes from your pain as
much as I love entrepreneurs and I think
entrepreneurs are gonna solve all the
world's major problems I like to say
it's not corporations it's not the
government like we're gonna do it it's
the problem with the world we're gonna
solve this what we do entrepreneurs as
much as I leaned in on the positive I
think really the why what you do comes
from pain and I think people are good
people in general like I think humans
are good I'm on team human I think I
think people are good and when you have
gone through something painful you just
naturally want to make it easier for
other people who are suffering that same
thing and I think human nature is to try
to avoid the pain forget the pain put it
behind us never go back there it's a
terrible place where I think if you
actually want to help people you need to
run back into your pain understand what
that meant to you and how how bad it was
and then whatever you did to get over it
then helping other people make the road
a little bit easier so for me
entrepreneurship was really painful I
was making 300 hours a month my first
company it was 19 I struggled a lot I
thought it would be hard but I didn't
think it would be that hard it was the
lowest time of my life
the worst self-confidence feeling like
I'm putting in so much effort and I'm
getting zero results from it and I just
felt kind of useless as a human being
and I the worst day of my life was I
told my business partner that I quit
and just cried my face off and the next
day got up and said I can't quit like I
just I could deal with the failure but I
couldn't deal with not knowing and so I
had to keep going
eventually it worked out we found
strategies we talked about that it's not
this you know terrible story it worked
out it was great but I still you know I
resonate more with the entrepreneur
who's struggling and like can't afford
to pay rent and there are a solo
entrepreneur then then the people who
have you know the fancy cars and all
that stuff even though we've had success
in my business now and so I just want to
make the road a little bit easier I was
too embarrassed and ashamed to tell my
friends that I couldn't I'd had no money
and I couldn't hang out with them I had
to pick one thing a month I'm making
three hundred bucks a month right it's
like it sucks and so I had to pick one
thing in a week a month that I could do
with my friends Pizza beer birthday
party and the rest were just telling
them I'm living the entrepreneur life
you know too busy and hustling hard you
know all the stuff that we say but
really like I just couldn't afford to go
out with them and honestly the I'm sure
they would have supported me and we
could have done something a lot cheaper
or no cost just hanging out at
somebody's house if I was just honest
with them
but I was just too embarrassed and
ashamed to say guys like I have no money
I can't you know and so I just I try to
make the content that I wish I had seen
when I was 19 getting started and my
passion is still helping entrepreneurs
and so as much as I talk about the why
so your question of I think
entrepreneurs will do all the amazing
things in the world it's really born
from the place if I suffered so much
emotionally and personally to build this
my own business that I just I know how
hard it is to get started as an
entrepreneur I just want to make the
road a little bit easier for the next
people who are starting up building the
muscle of stop caring of what other
people think is super valuable it took
me a long time to figure that out and
even today if I'm ever worried about
what somebody might think of me if
that's the reason not to do it then I
have to go and do it and it's not the
not to show it in their face and say
look how great I am it's just for you so
as an example I remember being in in my
hometown Toronto
we're here just for the weekend Nina's
have never been the boss in so I thought
we'd bring her out and explore the city
and I'm ever in Toronto I'd be walking
to this busy intersection and before I
got there I'd be listening to music in
my earbuds and I'd be on the streets
side streets and I'd be like groovin and
jiving you know dancing to my song one
word Tony mosey yeah and I get to the
busy intersection and then I just I
stopped because there are other people
there and when I caught that I thought
why am i playing small because of these
people I'm not offending them I'm not
trying to get in their face but I just
naturally play small because of the
people are watching me and so when I
caught it then I had the dents even
bigger than I would normally right I'm
like dancing up a storm on the corner of
a busy intersection in Toronto you're in
Shepherd of any you guys are local and
again it's not to get in their face or
say look at me it's just for me anytime
I feel the sense of I'm playing small
because of fear of judgment then I have
to go and do that thing the thing for me
is how many times did I go to that
intersection and just play small and
never catch it how many times did I have
my earbuds on and dance and just stop
dancing but never notice it you know
probably hundreds of times and so when
you catch it then you have to go and do
the thing so whenever you like even here
when when kids saying hey who wants to
come up and talk about themselves you
know the natural reactions that go my
god don't pick me don't pick me don't
pick me right and so if you ever feel
that if you can ever catch it there's
times are you're doing it automatically
but if you ever catch it that's not a
good reason like it's better to come up
here and totally suck and blank out and
you've got that's a friendly community
right like there's no tomatoes that are
going to be throwing at you maybe people
cheering you on if that's ever the
reason to not do something because
you're worried about looking stupid or
how you're going to be judged then then
you have to do it regardless of the
outcome regardless of anybody you know
spies your book or downloads your app or
goes to your website like that's not the
point it's not the promotion it's you
releasing that thing so I slowly started
building those muscles I think we all
have these big
missions we want to go off and change
the world and make a big impact that our
purpose comes from our pain and we want
to help like entrepreneurs want to help
to do those big things you have to be
able to take on a lot of you know a lot
of hate a lot of people who will
criticize you and how will you go off
and take do that big thing if you can't
even do a speech in front of here or
dance big on the street corner right you
go into the gym trying to lift like a
thousand pounds when you can't even lift
a five-pound dumbbell yet and so the
good news is you can train that and you
can get better at it every single time
and so just like as an encouraging
message the next time you feel yourself
playing small even today like if you are
nervous about introducing yourself to
somebody find the stranger and introduce
yourself just because like it doesn't
matter if they if they never go to your
website or app even if you lead off like
oh you know what I never introduce
myself and I'm just I just want to say
hi and then you walk away like that's
enough you just released it and so I
think we by default play small because
we're afraid of other people's opinions
and judgments and the more that you can
release at in the faster you can do it
the more you're able to move forward and
live the life that you want I think if
you're just thinking about starting up
just find a way to start it's crazy how
many excuses and we get stuck in
planning mode and planning and planning
come with the perfect plan you just you
got to just do something and I think a
lot of the value that I try to bring to
the people that I hang out with whether
they're micro-moments
here or one-on-ones at the coffee shop
we just came from or look people that I
even driving down from Boston with my
team is as soon as here's the thing when
you're around me as soon as you say I
wish I could do this then we're finding
a way to do that like right now right so
you know brahim my camera guy one of my
camera guys some DP vault on the way
down he's like yeah one day like I want
to post a story on Instagram but I don't
know what to say and I wonder if I go
live like how many people would show up
right it's like what we're doing both
we're driving down from Toronto it's
like 9 hours and and then he goes on
like you know how many dudes like 18
stories and a 45-minute live stream is
like now he's hamming it up it's like it
wasn't that big a deal but
just do it what are you gonna say it
doesn't matter nobody's watching anyway
post the thing like what are you so
afraid of right well I was driving he
was doing his stories in the backseat
and aim with switch legroom because I
need you know he's behind me so I got
long legs Shawn here you know he comes
into the coffee shop he just came from
and he comes in he says yeah one day I
want to start I wanna start vlogging and
he's like what what'd he do I'm a
musician oh cool what do you do I rap
you rap awesome you know Tony's a rapper
too
okay in this coffee shop we're gonna do
a rap right and so we got my camera crew
and and they did their own little
freestyle rap in the coffee shop alright
I grab another guy and he's afraid of
making stories we went outside and we
just made our first one-minute story
like just just do the thing find a small
way and just do the thing that you want
to do it's it's not that scary and even
if it is like just by doing it you
release it and you come back like why
was that so terrifying right and you
should be way further ahead than then
you are because you're just afraid and
because you get stuck in planning
planning planning planning mode you
can't plan your way to success like plan
is important but most of us are over
planners and I'm the same way like I
plan so much and I learned it because I
lost a 40 million dollar deal my first
business because I over planned and
didn't do enough doing and like that
needs to change think that's not cool so
that's one thing that I always try to
impart when I'm when I'm working with
people's whatever vision you have
whatever big dream like this what we're
good at we love thinking about the dream
and with the impact we want to have it's
amazing but just thinking about it's not
gonna do anything you got it you got to
do so what's the smallest possible way
to get started and then just start
building momentum so if the answer is
making YouTube videos great make youtube
videos and put one up every day even if
it sucks like the quantity will lead to
the quality the more you do it the
better you'll get I'm sure when Tony
started rapping it sucked and when he's
heard of public speaking he sucked right
like like everything we've ever tried to
do ever right and it's just practice and
getting better and put in the time in
and momentum and we're just too afraid
to start so whatever your big dream is
find some
small way and just do it right now that
that little bit of momentum is crazy how
far can take you you just get on a roll
so just start how do you turn your pain
into power in your fear into fuel yeah
it's a great question one starting with
if you have the awareness from what your
pain is so for me I lean in so heavy on
the positive and the optimism that I
just blanked out I don't remember the
past failures in the negativity so I had
to do a lot of a lot of work to just
uncover what the pain was you might know
it easily some people are more self
aware like I wasn't it was a process for
me once you have found it then you need
to see that it's easy to get lost in it
like putting yourself back if I put
myself back in that position of when I
told my business partner that I quit and
I just felt like a total failure as a
human being that sucks thinking about
that right it's a really crappy place to
be it's then just realizing that humans
are built to serve and if you're not
happy right now with your life then
you're not serving enough you're not
helping other people enough I think
we're just we are built to serve we want
to help other people I think it's part
of our DNA so how does your pain then
help serve others and it's one of two
ways either you either you dealt with
and you got through it so in my case I
solved the problem like I'm not I'm not
struggling to get by as an entrepreneur
anymore so I can give my story and my
strategies and my tactics on how I did
it because I know it worked for me and
hopefully it worked for you guys but
maybe you haven't solved it yet
like maybe you don't know what you're
doing yet maybe you're still in the pain
and even just sharing your journey of
what you're trying to do to overcome the
pain like if you're in that if you're in
your pain right now and you want to get
rid of it that is an inspiration to the
people because so many people are stuck
in that zone and they have no way to get
out and seeing you take the first path
take the first step like I want to make
your video great just seeing you make a
first video even if the video sucks like
it's better if it's
and they see you do it gives them a
shield
it gives them permission that they can
go off and do it too so it's just
thinking about what the pain is that you
if you have it right away you know it
great if not do some work to think about
it and then have you solved it and you
can give strategies on how to do it or
are you still working through it and
it's not don't come off as an expert on
something that you don't know what
you're talking about but your journey is
still valuable important
I can I can hang out with entrepreneurs
all day long like I'll go I'll forget to
go to the bathroom I'll forget to eat
you know I'll stay up all night like
it's just it fuels me because it's part
of the struggle that I went through if I
look at something like obesity or
depression I think those are really like
I think depression is super important to
solve I can that's about all I can say
about it cuz I've never gone through
depression so I can't authenticate Auk
about it I don't have strategies for you
I've never gone through it but if you've
gone through it and you've come out the
other side then being willing to share
the fact that you're dealing with this
thing I think that's like the biggest
first step is here's what I'm so afraid
of and show it to the world right and in
the fear of judgment right so like
Sheila's got a business around make up
and helping people who who've lost a lot
of weight and then have extra skin I had
to deal with it and she was inspired by
the guy who went shirtless and showed
off all his extra skin like that takes
an insane amount of bravery this is like
the thing that you are the most afraid
of and you're saying hey world look at
what I'm so afraid of right be that guy
for the thing you're afraid of because
when people see that then they get
inspired it's like well if he could do
it I could do it too and they may not
need to go on the website and like show
off their extra skin but a smaller step
for them might just be asking a girl out
right like some small step and you gave
them permission by you doing the thing
that you're afraid to do you gave them
permission to the thing that they're
afraid to do too so recognizing that
that thing that you're so afraid of is
your
strength because I can't talk about
extra skin and what you should do about
it
right but Sheila can and then I think I
think if you can then you must like I
think if you can then you have the
responsibility to so it's my
responsibility to help entrepreneurs I
can therefore I must whatever that pain
you went through you have to share it
and it doesn't mean you have to drag
down like maybe you you went through
abuse and you're your dad hit you or
something you don't listen to me to drag
your dad through the mud sometimes other
people are involved in the story but how
can you tell the story without
negatively impacting the people around
you but I think it's your responsibility
and I think ultimately you'll feel just
way better like you guys fuel me through
these things through the comments in the
YouTube channel like I wake up every day
knowing that the work that I do matters
and I'm not special
if anything I'm like super less than
special like 350 videos before I wasn't
totally embarrassed most people quit
after one or five right I just kept
going and I think all of you could like
whoever said video like I think you
could I think you could crush me way
faster it's just cuz I have done 6,000
videos right so like you better get
better at something if you've done it
6,000 times right it's hard not to so
yeah I think I think figuring out your
pain then recognizing that humans are
built to serve and
you must it is your responsibility to
give back and contribute and that will
be your ultimate satisfaction happiness
in life too
[Music]
you know I don't know that changes as
you as you grow or not I think I think
it's easy for everybody in this room to
feel overwhelmed regardless of if I have
you know 20 people working for me or not
right I think it starts with
understanding yourself so dissecting
yourself and what you love doing Jerry
Seinfeld says you have to do the thing
that other people would find torturous
but you love it
I'm sure if you stepped into my schedule
you would feel overwhelmed immediately
but it's not because I'm great like if I
jumped into your life I say this is
ridiculous I can't handle it like I'm
overwhelmed after five minutes and so
it's just understanding the way that you
need to schedule your life and build to
it so I love being I love having a
calendar I love everything lined out so
Monday know what I'm doing Tuesday I'm
doing something Wednesday and then I
like repeating my days so example
Tuesday is my YouTube day Tuesday I'm
I'm doing all the research I'm seeing
what my team has come together I'm
filming videos and then I don't touch
anything until next Tuesday and so one
it allows me to like be super productive
on Tuesday making on my YouTube videos
and then I I like to miss it right I
like I can't wait to go and film again
right that I don't get it and again
until Tuesday right and that works for
me like that may be the worst advice
ever for you right but having the
understanding of a schedule that works
for you and then designing your life
according to it and you may not be able
to do it fully yet right like you might
have a job you might have other
responsibilities is that you're working
your way through but if every month
you're taking a little bit closer step
you take a half hour an hour more every
week to start working on the thing that
you're doing and spending less time than
the stuff that you hate according the
schedule that you want so it's how it's
a difficult question ask because I don't
live your life right but I don't think
it's any easier or difficult as you get
like I like I like people I like I like
the people on my team and I want them to
grow as people you know Danny and brahim
my two video guys and I where he MS some
where he went to the washing good
we can talk about him while he's that in
a good way
their ultimate goal is to build like a
Netflix special they want to film
content for Netflix right and now
they're doing like wedding photography
and a bunch of stuff and so this is a
step it looked great I want I want my
thing to be a platform to help you give
go get your Netflix special even if that
means you're gonna leave me if you're
with me for six months or two years or
whatever and then you're doing Netflix
like I'm so happy for you
we were we were scoping out his his show
on the way down like on the way down the
Boston like Danny what do you ultimately
want to do I want to I want to make a I
want to make like a two-hour video I
want to make a movie okay so how do we
like let's make it five minutes short
like start what nobody's gonna say here
here's a million dollars gonna make it
to our movie right so let's make a five
minutes short what does that look like
and it's like okay I don't know how to
crunch it down into five minutes because
it's a big story great let's look we've
got eight hours you know like let's work
through it right tell me what the story
is and we started working through it I
gave my perspective I'm like I can't
tell him how to do his art but just in
breaking them down we came up with a
script that can work for him and just in
like a half hour or 45 min the
conversation he's got enough to go off
and build his five minutes short I wake
up this morning I'm up til 3:30 last
night we wake up early cuz I'm always
afraid that I'm gonna miss the alarm so
when I'm traveling I always end up
waking super early I got like no sleep I
had no sleep the night before the first
thing I'm doing is finding spots for
Danny to shoot his video because he
wants to do an airplane thing and you
can't go to an airport and shoot but
there's a spot in Toronto where the
planes are flying over this gas station
like you can go and film there and get
the shot that he wants I got to show him
like a screen candle what that looks
that's what I'm doing the first thing I
know I'm in bed researching Google
Images to find the spot so that when he
wakes up is a gay need Hey look at this
right so but that's me like I want the
people on my team to win for as long as
they're with me and if they leave then I
want them to leave and like go do your
thing
so I schedule my life and build my life
and business as much as possible around
the things that I love doing and I try
to make that happen I think that's one
of the greatest things that being
entrepreneurs you can design the life
and the business that you want so it's
really understanding what is
overwhelming in your life right now and
what does an ideal schedule look like
and then it's it's I'm not the like burn
the boats guy and kill all your other
responsibilities and just go all in and
do it I think you just if you have
confidence that this is working like you
have a plane like by the end of the year
I want to eliminate this and you work
towards making to happen and it's solely
your schedule becomes more and more what
you wanted to look like I think if you
know where you're gonna be in five years
are thinking small I think idea that you
know the kind of person you need to be
in five years means that you're not
exploring and doing enough stuff to
really figure yourself out I think it's
possible to work towards a five year
goal but I think if you hit that I feel
like you could have done way more if you
were just open to life and reacting and
changing along the way because you won't
be the same person in five years as you
are now so I don't worry so much about
having a five year goal I think about
life time the big thing that I'm trying
to accomplish my big mission that's
never gonna happen but I'm I'm everyday
trying to make it a little tiny dent in
it and then just what am i doing
next what's coming up like when we doing
for the next couple months and almost
nothing in between I want to I want to
solve the world's biggest problem I
think it's untapped human potential I
think people are doing the wrong thing I
think most people are just doing the
wrong thing I don't think most people
wake up and are just excited about life
and are doing work that is meaningful to
them I think everybody has Michael
Jordan level talent at something or Tom
Brady level talent
at something I don't think Tom Brady is
that special
I don't think Tom Brady is the best
football player of all time he's not
he's not the best the best quarterback
of all time is a manager at Starbucks
because he never picked up a football
that's how most people are living their
life you have Tom Brady level talent at
something you're just not doing it I
think that's most people so I don't
think that Tom Brady is special I
definitely don't think that I'm super
special I think everybody has that in
them they just don't even believe is my
one where it's a they don't believe that
they can you know I see something like
cancer I think we should have really
called I think we should have already
solved cancer I think I think I think
the woman who will solve cancer is an
accountant right now and whether she
knew that she should have taken biology
and got held back or her parents told
him not to do it or she just never tried
it wasn't part of her awareness and now
she's an accountant and she hates her
life you could have solved cancer right
that's how I see the world so I think I
think all of you have Tom I'm used to
seeing Michael doing Tom Brady level
talent at something and so it's finding
it and when you found it then believing
in yourself enough to chase it every day
and go be Tom Brady how do I stay in
flow and how do I plan the days when I'm
not in flow I don't I don't think that
we're in flow that often I'm not even
flow every day and I think we fool
ourselves a lot of times like I'm in
flowing through these emails
yeah I'm really crushing this like you
know
that's yes and so what I do is I have
this and this works for me again right
you got to figure out works for you I
have my schedule and I stick to my
schedule I know what I'm doing every day
of the week and I'm pretty excited and
pumped about that and we schedule in
family stuff as much it was vigil
everything else in but then when I mean
when I really get going on something
when I hit flow on something then I try
to stay there as long as possible I'll
push almost everything possible aside to
do that thing so in example since my
wife is here at the back I I wanted to I
decided while we're on a cruise in
September that I wanted to finish my
second book on the anniversary date of
my first book so your one words my first
book top ten was a success is my second
one and I decided took me like I don't
know six months to write half the book
because it was like picking away at it
and I just decided December 6 the book
has to be out and I was mid September
we're on a cruise ship there's a lot of
work that has to get done I had to
finish writing half of it and then
proofread you know artwork everything
it's crazy so it meant that by the end
of the cruise I had to finish the book
so I told Nina Nina I need to finish my
book and you know while Nina was
sleeping I was working my book well Nina
was working at it I was working on my
book we still went to the ports and the
cruises stops and we did our stuff and
then every extra moment I was working on
my book
and I never do that like I don't I have
a cellphone but I don't have a cell
phone number because when I'm with Nina
I'm with Nina you can't call me right so
I really value my family time but I was
in the zone and I had to finish that and
she understood and the only reason why
she understood is because I already had
so much I mean she can come up and talk
about it but in my words I had enough in
the emotional bank account if that was
our life every single week we wouldn't
be together right like she would have
she would have dumped me because I don't
spent any time with her
but that's how I see the world and that
whenever I get in the flow on something
I try to stay there for as long as
possible and push everything off for as
long as possible even though it means
short-term sacrifices in some other area
of my life for business because what I'm
gonna create in that moment is gonna be
gold it's gonna be gold when you aren't
flowing you're creating like it will be
gold so I will stay up until my eyes are
burning and I will push meetings and
apologize and I know what can make it up
to people because I need to stay there
but I'm not there that often right
that's not a deal and maybe a just maybe
I just suck like great but for me I'm
not there that often so for the days
that I'm not there I have my schedule so
I'm not waking up I say what am I gonna
do today I don't know let me wait for my
flow and I don't know it's like explore
and do something right so that that's
but that's me like I don't want to force
what I do on you but that's the way that
I think about it is when I'm inflating
to see you there for as long as
absolutely possible and push everything
as much as possible and then for
everything else I scheduled designed the
life that I want and that works for me I
think when you have a goal you need to
look at for me we have a goal you look
to your schedule you have a goal say I
want to be you know Sean I want to be
the world's greatest rapper great let's
look at your schedule how much time I
spent rapping right like if you're not
rapping every day you're not gonna get
there so what's in your schedule has to
help you go and get the goal that you
want if you have your goal and your
schedule doesn't help you get those
things you're not gonna get that goal
you just talking right so remember going
like a Tony Robbins event unleash the
power within in California everybody's
getting rrragh which is great like I
love to when we've collab with his team
but for me as soon as I learned
something it goes right to the schedule
like how do I put this in my schedule so
it's a regular habit cuz otherwise just
motivation and that's gone the next week
when you come back home with floor this
is why I think five-year goals suck so
I'm walking to five your little side
that's all that's gonna make you
Instagram right no contacts five-year
goals suck every time when I'm walking
to a coffee shop two weeks ago and on
the way
I've been thinking about Danny Brahimi
to video guys and they talked me how
much they love travelling Nina loves
travelling for me it's okay like I've
traveled so much the best part is this
to be honest like I'd rather spend all
day meeting with local entrepreneurs
then seeing a bridge or a park or
whatever right like this is the thing
for me so I just decided I want to visit
with Nina because she loves traveling
every city in Canada in the US that has
a million people plus in the area I just
decided we had a long weekend coming up
so Monday's a holiday for us it's our
Independence Day - July 1st you guys
have to like fourth and I said okay
what's the closest city that we can get
to that we hadn't been to Boston great
we're gonna Boston Nina should we bring
Danny brahim so yeah I invite them I
want to be on the channel more okay the
any Bri humor coming to God you want to
come to Boston yep great I put out some
Instagram videos and newsletters and I
find out Tony's in Boston I didn't know
that we just collabed on this video went
live his one-word video went live on my
channel last week and Tony's in Boston
great she live in contact on Twitter she
was in Boston awesome
KITT messages me so hey I got I got this
awesome group Boston speaks I can
organize an event awesome
like all this came together super quick
but it wasn't part of my 5-year plan
right I decided I want to do it we had a
long weekend coming up let's go to
Boston and now all of this is possible
because of it and maybe I meet somebody
here then changes the entire trajectory
of what I end up doing right but because
we're so locked in on making our
five-year plan happen you're not open to
the opportunity of something amazing
happening to in your life so there's a
thing that we don't like been a
recurring theme through the past like
couple months for me is everything is
the best like when something goes wrong
it's the best so we almost didn't put
this on because because there's fire
alarms that are being tested or
something in the building or was or
whatever like I want to do it with the
fire alarms on like it's the best right
like things never go according to plan
right and so when they don't go
according to plan that's the best then I
want to do it even more
and I just trained myself that whenever
something is not great like this is the
best right and you lean in on it cuz
because negativity is coming for you
you can't avoid it like even if you do
zero with your life there will be
negative things that happen like people
in your family will die and like lots of
negativity will happen so so what do you
do when something negative comes for you
how do you react to it right there's
nothing good nor bad it's thinking that
makes it so right you choose to react in
the positive way
so when why'd she do this I had a
workshop in Toronto in May and we had
two fire alarm go off and I ran down to
the the secondary place we're doing it
it's like guys it's the best I went to
see everybody's like is the report now
record with the alarm going off this is
amazing right and then and I have my
dogs with me 24/7 and one of them is a
puppy she peed on the floor while I'm
doing my speech like here right my
puppies on my lab gets down pees on the
floor and I just keep going that guy's
the best right right like you just go
with him then becomes a thing right
where it's easy to get distracted and
it's not it's not the perfect ideal
thing that you thought of and so now you
can't post and you can't do the thing
that you want to do right you do it
regardless like you do it and like that
makes you stronger when you do it when
it's difficult that's when it's awesome
if you're running the race against
three-year-olds you're gonna win every
time you're gonna hate it nobody wants
to run a race against three-year-olds
right
the challenges are where you grow so
when you feel a challenge and like this
is the best jump in on it do it you have
to do it so I would have done it with I
want the fire lamp like I want something
to pull the fire line right now like
it's awesome it's the best but if the
power love went off and if there was a
fire here right and like we're still
staying here we you know make it out it
would be like the best story of all time
right it's the best right like we make
it we can we can run pretty quickly to
get the door right but it's like a fire
erupts and we all have to take off I
would still continue this Q&A on the
streets while there's fire trucks and
would be the best memory you guys would
have
for the year right at least it would be
for me well then instance what was the
worst-case scenario that you went into
and then somehow you came out I have
such a hard time thinking to negative
spots like besides when you don't have
when I was I'm trying to think of
something recent I don't know guys help
me what was negative that we turned
around to something yeah I mean some of
that's like way back like I didn't think
that was the best but ultimately like
but but but but it has been like that
that is for him to laughing bring him
make sure you're not shaking the camera
that lesson taught me not to be a
perfectionist because I was I had to
have the perfect plan have a perfect
pitch perfect plan and I never I never
kickstart I never never give it the push
and I lost a 40 million dollar deal that
pisses me out and it's the best right
like it's the biggest lesson of all time
the pain that I suffered as an
entrepreneur making 390 bucks a month
and feeling like a total loser and
having no back is what fueled my entire
channel it's the best I had a biotech
software company early-stage biotechs
software and there was a lot of
consolidation happening in our industry
and actually picked we're thinking who's
gonna buy us and we picked the right
industry of who would buy us but we
picked the wrong company and here's a
lesson like whenever you're picking you
think someone's gonna buy you out it's
never the number one player was gonna
buy you it's a number four player who
wants to become the number one player
and that was our problem we targeted it
just made so much sense for how our
software would fit with this number one
player and everything would be
integrated to be amazing they just
didn't care because of the number one
player it was a number four player who
raised an 800 million dollar fund who
was going to acquisition spree that we
caught too late we were targeting the
wrong company and we were we were at the
end like it was us and our biggest
competitor and we lost to our biggest
competitor so like we were number two we
were the bridesmaid right
now so I don't know it's not the
expression there's a Canadian thing it
was a groomsman we were the groomsmen I
don't wanna get in trouble and I just
got my boss and ain't for everybody
t-shirt I want to be able to keep and
not get kicked out of the city
we were the groomsmen and it's not to
say that we would have gotten a deal if
we were more prepared but we would have
had at least a better shot all right so
just the last time you learned another
one like it's the best it's the best
lesson but it's a it's a that let that
pain taught me that if I ever want to
get into an industry and I want to make
partnerships you want to target the
aggressive number three four five six
player not the number one they don't
they won't care about aggressive growth
right so if she's trying to sell her app
who's gonna buy her app it won't be the
number one company yeah yeah hopefully
right and if not then then you'll eat
the lesson in yourself and right but
that's that's the goal right like and
that was my pain so I want to make it
easier for the next gen right whatever
your pain is you can now make you tell
your story some people will listen some
people won't but you're trying at least
and making the impact through your
message you know I think for me if you
know the thing that you need to do then
like I secretly want you to leave right
now and go film your video and maybe
come back if we're still here right I
don't have a group I mean for me I just
wanna I'm here for you like I love I
want to help I have no agenda I'm not
trying to sell anything and there's no
point that I need to talk about whatever
whatever brings the most value to you
guys if it's this format continuing it's
great if it's you want to work with
yourselves in a group and I popped
around and say hi awesome like it
doesn't matter to me
I'm turns of steam motivated the three
things that I come up with is one your
big why like what why why why do you do
this thing like for me helping
entrepreneurs is a super strong wine so
why do you do your thing that's the big
why the little why is number two and the
little why is sometimes the big wise so
when I come up and say I'm trying to
solve the world's biggest problem right
like that's ridiculous sometimes you're
big why is too big and you're scared of
it like a little Who am I to go off and
do this thing right but the little wise
just remembering that you helped one
person right so for me I just go to my
YouTube
and like you guys are all full of love
and it's amazing but when I was just
getting started as a speaker I would I
would make a PowerPoint file of all the
feedback that I got from people and we
just look at that every morning because
I do a speech and people would love me
and then I wake up the next day and like
life sucks right
so just remembering that you helped one
person like you may not be anywhere
close to what you want to do but you
helped one person and that is awesome
and then the third thing is just having
a routine that that gets you excited in
the morning like what a reverse engineer
saw whatever gets you motivated and
feeling unstoppable you've already felt
that in the past what led you to feel
that and then put that into morning
routine with us watching video reading
the Booker or like doing yoga on the
balcony with your cat in your arm or
like whatever who cares like do the
thing that does matter like it's about
you being awesome doesn't matter with
other people think about the thing that
you need to do right if you woke up and
did the thing that made you feel
unstoppable every day your life and one
year would be totally different than
what it is right now the more you do the
better you'll get if you're posting six
times a day on Instagram you'll get
better like you pay attention what
people are responding to we're finding
your own message you will slowly get
better stories I do three to five a day
again you get I don't know what I'm
doing oh that button okay great Oh post
that right that's the best story ever I
love that story right it's the best
right it's cuz because when you post
something like that you post this thing
that makes zero sense you've just
released a fear of posting like nobody
cares that you posted it and you've just
released a fear it's amazing we were
filming the stories of the brahim in the
car and I was so upset about how many
takes he was doing on these things that
we were going at the border we were
going over a speed bump and I I sped up
to go over the speed bump and then
stopped hard and everybody's like wow
and like bring him you better post that
post right now I'm never gonna be in any
of your posts ever again in history
right because you need like I just post
it just release the fear being perfect
all the time right and the more you do
the better you'll get so I would I would
map to your ambition I would think like
what do you if you want to get better be
with health stories quick videos then I
would I wouldn't make as many as you put
like I try to do five times a day and
just slowly get better better better
better better better I decided to not
live my life with regret
I'll tell in heard this story but it's a
dating story so she anyway I never told
my friend Anita anyway we'll tell it
here we go it's the best drink when I
was 19 in with the Paris and I had my
map out and I'm standing us at the Notre
Dame Cathedral and a girl comes up to me
in perfect French asking for directions
and I'm like not this I'm an ass's girl
that hey go for coffee or whatever why
she asked me in perfect French how to
get somewhere a railing
anyway I chickened out right I'm like I
am too afraid I'm scared I don't ask her
she leaves I take a picture of like I
try to get a picture of her across the
stream this before digital cell phones
and digital cameras right so like it
gets I'm 38 so that's 20 years ago the
picture comes out I don't get her Jesus
anyway so this is a picture of this
french Riverside I take it I blow it up
and I put it on my wall at home and
every day I look at that picture as a
reminder to not live with regret as a
reminder to tell myself that the next
time I get faced with an opportunity
what was I so I was afraid of rejection
I was afraid of failure and I wanted to
develop the mindset that I can deal with
failure and rejection I can't deal with
not knowing I have to know and so I look
at that picture every day I didn't tell
anybody when people came into my room
said oh yeah that's a beautiful picture
yeah it's from my trip to France not
that I'm looking at every day it's like
I will not live when regret and then I
got the opportunity to take my dream job
you know 80 hundred K a year traveling
around the world the banking job I
thought I wanted versus the 300 L a
month startup company that'd be an owner
in and because I've been looking at that
picture every day I cited you know what
this startup may fail it may not work I
can always go get another job it may not
be that job it's a different job but I
cannot deal with not knowing I can deal
with the company flaming out and
crashing and burning but I don't want to
be ten years in some corporate job
thinking what if I just tried that
startup business so that lesson is still
how I filter a lot of my decisions I
don't want to live with regret and I
make the future regret so painful I
imagine like whatever I'm afraid to do
or I imagine just fifty years of like
that thing would have been the best
thing ever like if I'm nervous to come
here like the Boston speaks saying would
be the thing that just defined my career
be like the best thing of all time and I
missed it I didn't do it because I was
afraid right I just I just pile on so
much maybe I'm a masochist and like
maybe this won't work for you but I just
pile on so much future fear so that the
present fear of doing the thing isn't
that scary
so it's like if you have a hangnail it's
really bugging you it's like you punch
yourself in the arm you don't fear the
hangnail anymore right that's basically
what I do
if the hangnail of like coming here is
scary then I'll just punch myself in the
arm and just not doing it becomes just
insanely scary for the next 50 years so
then I have to go up and do that thing
saya works for me you mean uh that that
was the biggest one of the biggest
things if just deciding not to live with
regret so I don't go to books what I'm
struggling
I go to videos I make the videos that I
need to to see even now I make the video
like every video that I post on my
channel
I've by watch and I I've learned
something from it if I haven't learned
something from it I don't post it so I
still go to my channel selfishly for
myself because I want to be around Elon
Musk and Oprah and all these people and
so it's selfish for me and I share it
and thankfully you guys love it too so
that I can build business around there
which is awesome we all win but I don't
I don't go to books anymore really so I
don't have ideas for you there the first
part was around Oh what do you do when
the public hates your thing and write
one like it's the best right - it's
still you now have to decide is it just
that you suck right now and that it will
get better right like if you want to be
a speaker you will suck at the beginning
but as you practice you will get better
and so is it is it worth it like is
yours is your mission worth it
understand that all this pain and
struggling and suffering is ultimately
how you're gonna win because dealing
with the haters will now allow you to
help other people who are dealing with
haters where if you succumb to it you're
gonna hate your life and help nobody
right so if that has to happen like if
the path forward has to happen that
mission is so important to you then all
of these struggles and insecurities and
conquering them is the best like that's
how you're gonna win you have to
overcome those and then you be the
shield for the people who are suffering
those same things and you're gonna say I
get it I understand what you're dealing
with hop on board I'm gonna help you
like you climb up a step when you you
you put your hand down and pull somebody
up to join you right and that's that's
what you just keep doing you keep
picking people and pulling them up to
where you're at and the more you deal
with these situations and struggles the
higher you climb up with the steps and
the
people you can climb up to join you
right it's just is that mission
important enough to you if it's not then
then quit immediately I move on to
something else but the fact that you are
concerned about you're so concerned
about the hate and the and what people
are thinking means that you must do it
just to release it right I was at a nail
spa with my dancing team right Thailand
dance company too and we won a local
competition so I took I took them out to
a nail spa and I went with them and then
one of the women joke like hey haven't
you gonna get your nails done and my
instinct immediately was no that's
stupid but but why because I have
meetings and I have I have speaking gigs
I'm making YouTube videos I can't go out
with nail polish on it's ridiculous but
because that was the reason I had to do
it the only acceptable reason is I don't
express myself through nail polish which
is why I don't have it on now
right but because I was worried about
the judgment of meeting these people and
doing videos and speaking gigs then I
had to do it and so I did it and I
painted my nails full orange and then
realize wow these don't look good so so
then I put a white racing stripe across
all of them right and so and then I wore
that's how that's why I walked out and
then as I started chipping off I kept it
on because that was the next level
people looked at it and said your nails
are gross right you need to you need to
you need to especially the women like
you need to remove that and like like
because of that judgement that's why I'm
doing it right I love it I want to eat
that judgment and now I don't need to
like I can wear nail polish and it's not
a thing but I don't that's not how I
express myself so I don't do it anymore
but when you're feeling the hate and the
judgment for me at least it's a path
that I need to go off and do that thing
just to release that demon so that you
don't care about those people's opinions
anymore and then you can teach other
people how to do it too so the most
rewarding thing is just knowing that the
work that I do matters it's this like
it's meeting you guys as helping
entrepreneurs feeling like I do
something today that meant something to
help other people you know I think
humans are built to serve and so it's
what I try to do every day I don't
always do the best job but I try
in terms of uncomfortableness yeah even
now like even having these camera guys
on me one of the things with my channels
I've known I've always historically hid
behind like I'm most known for the top
ten rules right it's not even me and I
get a lot of like what kids said hey I
wish you were more in the content and
I'm trying to figure out ways to do that
right like we're recording this today
you know we'll see how it goes I think
there's a lot that I bring when I help
people one on one that never gets
documented and recorded so that's part
of that's uncomfortable for me it's what
I'm starting to share so some of it is
planning it's like okay I need to break
out of my shell more and like make some
more content and we'll see where it goes
and some of it is just in the moment
like getting hit with the nail polish
the thing is that for that is this the
awareness because it's easy to say no
that's stupid for the nail polish but
why is it stupid right and the only
acceptable answer is I don't express
myself to nail polish but the real
reason was I'm just afraid and a lot of
the times the reason why you don't do
something we will logically come up with
something to say here's why I'm not
doing it and it make total sense
and this you know the smarter you are
the better the reasons you have for not
doing something right but the only real
reason is that deep down behind you're
afraid and that is not an acceptable
reason how would you say listen I know
we've gotten some good energy here in
the room and and hopefully you guys met
some new people here too
if I've given anything to you I think
the most important thing is take that
energy and do something with it today
no matter how small like that one thing
that you guys were yelling out or in the
back your head like try to find one
thing to do today even if it feels
stupid ridiculous
tiny small like I'm gonna make a video
great like just go make a one-minute
Instagram video feel awkward and
terrible and just totally embarrassed
and ashamed and then press post like
there you go there we go see
on here he said do the video this is it
we're doing it live okay so here we go
what do we what are we talking about
he is the mascot for our books yeah so I
have a family that's crazy about stuffed
animals and they're the reason I
actually did this so most adults would
hold him and do exactly weird with the
wings right I feel like as soon as I
hold him I want to flap the wings I feel
like this needs this guy needs to be a
cartoon character and he like flies off
and says something yeah or like have a
little thing at the back that I can like
pull down and it makes it flap that be I
know it's next-level expensive but but
even this this is great hunter the owl
[Music]
[Laughter]
so if I've given you a name like do that
and but but but do it on you and and
it's likely gonna suck and that's the
best right no but like everywhere this
like just do it on you like go out and
do the thing whether it's recording a
video or making a phone call or asking
that guy out or whatever like just do it
and and if you get rejected it's awesome
because it's not about the result it's
about the fact that you did you did
something to get out of your funk and
you're just constant life and say I'm
gonna shoot for something bigger whether
you hit it or not the first time doesn't
matter it's the fact that you're
shooting and you're shooting every day
you're gonna hit eventually and that's
the process altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video